ويشعر المسؤولون الأمريكيون والأوروبيون
بالقلق من أن الرئيس بوتين ربما
يأخذ الانتخابات الرئاسية لعام 2024 في الاعتبار
في نهجه بشأن الحرب في أوكرانيا، ويعتمد
بشكل أساسي على احتمال
أنه إذا خسر الرئيس بايدن وفاز ترامب
أو أي مرشح جمهوري آخر،
فإن الدعم الأمريكي لأوكرانيا سيتضاءل،
وهو ما سيتضاءل بالطبع.
يفيد بوتين والآن لا يعد هذا
تقييمًا استخباراتيًا أمريكيًا ثابتًا وثابتًا لعقلية بوتين، لكن
المسؤولين الأمريكيين يعتقدون أنه يأخذ
ذلك في الاعتبار، وكما
قال أحد الخبراء، فهو في الأساس
ضوء محتمل في نهاية النفق بالنسبة لبوتين
من شأنه أن يؤدي إلى سقوطه.  أي احتمال
للتوصل إلى حل قريب المدى لهذه الحرب، من
الواضح أننا نعلم الآن أن احتمال التوصل إلى
حل قريب المدى منخفض للغاية الآن،
ولكن هذا قد يحفز أنصار بوتين
القلقين في الولايات المتحدة وأوروبا على
تمديد الحرب حتى نوفمبر المقبل.
عام كايلي أتوودز سي إن إن واشنطن